episode 89 of congratulations is brought
to you by the cash app you already know
the cash app is the number one finance
app on the App Store what you might not
know is that you can also put cash app
in your wallet with the cash card
it's got boosts it's got great safety
features no credit check needed to get
one we'll talk about this more later on
in the show so don't worry if you still
want to hear about it it's coming up
later
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market and do
it now what's up my babies
how's it going your boys coming to
Florida Miami Jacksonville other [ __ ]
places West Palm Beach
let's get those tickets you know go to
crystal Viacom follow the leader tour
that's where we're hitting next of
course we aren't in other places but
they are sold out yeah Miami West Palm
Beach Jacksonville are the other ones in
Atlanta Georgia that's where I'm coming
I just added a show in Los Angeles
California and San Francisco's pretty
much sold out there's one in
Massachusetts Fresno Bakersfield Austin
and San Antonio but yeah so you know
what man did I bite my lip this week
yeah is it still in a lot of [ __ ]
pain yeah no did I bite my lip or did
about my tongue about metemma tongue and
that's the worst when you bite your
tongue your life's over your life is
over until it heals and since we're not
Wolverine it takes too long to heal they
say that but people say yeah you do
you know the mouth is the quickest thing
to heal the mouth is the quickest part
of your body that heals no it doesn't
feel like it because you're talking with
your mouth all the time and when you
talk with your mouth it [ __ ] makes it
take longer when it heals and that's
annoying now I bit my tongue and I sound
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] I said every time
I bet my my lip by the way I talked so
fast and [ __ ] sometimes and I eat real
fast I bite my lip all up I got my
tongue all the time all the time and it
takes about [ __ ] six days to heal am
Irish buddy said he'd rather burned his
tongue than bite his tongue and now
got me BRM that got me blood-red mad
because here's the deal
burning your tongue isn't that bad it's
not that bad
biting your tongue is harrowing biting
your tongue is the worst [ __ ] thing
biting your tongue biting your lip it
sucks it [ __ ] sucks it sucks big-ass
donkey dicks it sucks big donkey balls
so but that's by the way I talk real
quick I eat real quick I talked about
this once on the podcast
I'm listening where we're live on my hat
by the way if you want to hear it if you
want to see my podcast first before
anyone else gets to see it you get on my
app you download my app hit Crysta just
typing Chris D'Elia wherever apps are
and you click on that and you download
it and some of the babies are listening
right now but I bite my lip about my
tongue and because I eat cuz I talk
about cerebal fast but here's the deal
man
I real [ __ ] fast and I eat remember
when remember when I said I ate a lot
ice-cream sandwiches that one episode a
long time ago well I did it again I
[ __ ] say size some sandwiches now let
me tell you something man well I know I
talked about this whole portion control
[ __ ] bro if you [ __ ] eat if you eat
like two or three cookies I got I got
nothing in common with you man people
who eat a bag of chips you're out see ya
people who eat one of those [ __ ]
travel bags you know I'm talking about
that you bring a lunch with school bring
bring bring with bring the school to
have for lunch I can't do it dude I
ordered a bunch of cookies because I
thought it would be a good idea to just
pick and choose which one I wanted I
just I'll eat them all dude it always
feels good in my mouth when I put those
cookies in no matter how full I am my
stomach
people think they eat a lot you don't
eat [ __ ] oh it drives me nuts and girls
do it a lot cuz I feel like they're
overcompensating they want to be like
you know I'm crazy I'm so [ __ ] insane
and I eat so much I'm like always eating
um hello I'm like always eating no no
dude that ain't [ __ ] you're a bird dude
I eat like a hippo I I'm a [ __ ]
termite dude all
eat everything in sight man I eat eat
eat eat emcees what's that [ __ ] Mike
Tyson is on that one cannabis saw is it
the cannabis song you always thought we
talked hurry I II II e EE MCS Mike Tyson
when he said his children oh okay I'm
losing endorsements I losing
endorsements hey hey hey what's up Mike
Tyson we're sprite we'd love for you to
I eat your children never mind dude I
[ __ ] I eat yo cannabis you may need
JEP give out here to do nothing but
e-e-e-e MCS for lunch breakfast hey man
even blame me on my life man you know I
wanted title a couple times D right
nobody taking hurt us man we're gonna do
it get up in this wing man put on his
let me show you how to hit yourself man
hey man Mike Tyson
you can't talk about eating MCS or
eating peoples children anyway but also
you can't talk about that because you
ate someone's ear okay so um so yeah so
no I I can i I just can eat eat it all
[ __ ] one plate two plates [ __ ]
three plates if it's Chinese food three
plates do it feel like [ __ ] a whole day
after yeah do I wake up and do I go work
out and when I'm working out I have to
stop and then go take a number two in
the middle yeah am i sweating all over
the toilet
yeah but am I gonna do it Kenny yes I am
dead again that's what's up dude eat eat
eat eee mcs breakfast IE no i lunch like
breakfast breakfast lunch and dinner
um now but i I can't stop dude I I don't
know what it is especially late at night
dude that late at night a comfy [ __ ]
when you're just sitting in a hotel bed
because what I do since lonely but even
if I'm at home jim-jim
oh they got post mates again post mates
you'd get you know maybe die early
because it can't stop eating
I was talking my dad my dad was like
yeah sometimes I like to just write you
know I stopped before I want to I want
to keep going but I stopped I'm like dad
I don't understand I'm a mmm insatiable
anyway I want to [ __ ] figure out this
eating thing cuz I'm 38 I'm still a
little bit of a young buck you know what
I'm talking about him very young but uh
I can do it but when you're 55 you can't
do it do it
I heard that Robert Downey jr. was had
to work out in between takes and Ironman
because he was trying to [ __ ] keep
fit you know I mean um I don't know dude
I don't really know how it goes with the
whole [ __ ] also the sugar thing I got
to stop eating sugar sugars the [ __ ]
drug man do - why is Chinese food so
good that's what I want to know when you
[ __ ] eat okay so here's the deal
Italian food number one me I think that
Italian food number one number two close
second Chinese food now if Chinese foods
good that might usurp Italian food okay
Sushi's up there also if you don't like
sushi I get it um and then there's good
Mexican which is [ __ ] amazing I don't
know dude ah did you guys see the UFC
fight how crazy was that dude by the way
which what number is it which one is it
- 2 9 no no this the how do I do the new
thing on the cowboy and didn't tell me
oh here we go okay did a new thing - the
soundboard did you guys watch UFC 2 - 9
did you watch that dude first of all I
don't really watch those fights I'll
watch him in the beginning when I did
jujitsu 4 I did it for like five six
years and when I was getting into it it
was like 2001 I was watching UFC I sorts
and all the old VHS tapes of the [ __ ]
I think I had VHS tapes of it we had if
we still had to record a video of VHS
thing and we were watching what do you
call it we would watch all the guys when
it was style
versus style you know what I mean it was
like karate guy versus [ __ ] boxer you
know it was like some real street
fighter [ __ ] that son of a [ __ ] I'm
going to kick that son of a [ __ ] Bisons
as short the next bison wannabe is going
to feel it now who's coming with me and
what's going on
that's a jean-claude Van Damme from
Street Fighter II for the movie but yeah
dude he it would be like jiu-jitsu guy
versus Hawk you know it was like such
different it was like Muay Thai guy
versus Komodo dragon and it'll be a
mootai guy and he'd be doing his Muay
Thai [ __ ] just on like bouncing around
and then they'd let a komodo dragon in
the ring and the Komodo dragon would
just bite him and then poison him
no but my point is is that it was way
different every style was way different
they'd be like wrestler versus ninjutsu
guy and yeah but that's what it was in
the beginning and then the Jiu Jitsu
guys kept winning and so that's why
jujitsu blew up and then I stopped
because I [ __ ] my knee [ __ ] up
anyway I finally watched another fight
this one this Conor McGregor is it
khabib because everyone's saying Habib I
don't know either Ches in the front so
either it's silent or not khabib non-jew
connecticut khabib Nagy again not again
whatever the [ __ ] his name is and Conor
McGregor dude first of all it was crazy
watching that guy like actually dominate
Conor McGregor that guy's so good at
grappling right and he won and it was
awesome and it was an awesome moment and
then he [ __ ] it all up by attacking
did you see the the memes where they
made him an eagle because of the how he
was pouncing down it I mean he literally
looked like an eagle picking up a fish
but yeah that guy it's so weird to hear
him talk afterwards because like
Russians are so [ __ ] different dude
they're so different like I used to do
bid on this but like imagine a Russian
guy like making love to a woman I can't
that's probably racists and Prejudice of
me but I can't imagine like a Russian
guy making sweet love to a woman he's
just like what you take you take that
guy's like a an Italian guys like yeah
but you have to make sweet love you have
to do this for that it's good for the
woman and then the Russian guys like do
you take you turn them around did you
take you take them you turn her round
she offers herself to you you take you
grab you take you know Italians gala yes
but it is a symbiotic thing you take it
is it is a given Deco relationship you
know you give it you get you give her
pleasure she like and then it makes you
happy and he's and Russian guys like you
take you come he o it is over but does
she climax and Russian guy is just like
what does she climax what she doesn't
have penis how does she climax well
where does sperm come out of fur girl
like what no you make her feel good you
touch the [ __ ] what a woman has a clear
woman has what the woman has cleared it
all at the pleasure the sensory you
touched the cleared and it makes a woman
feel good it pops out on top of her the
pose here and the Russian guys like you
say woman has penis woman has little
penis on top of her no no no no no it's
clear does he have balls never mind
that's how a conversation would go with
an Italian and Russian talking bah
but my point is when the jernigan
russian a golf whatever [ __ ] his name is
khabib the jernigan russian and off when
he was he won and
and he was like okay well he talked [ __ ]
about my dad though we gotta finish this
got a bit to [ __ ] that everybody in his
camp you know the other guy from the
bottom was like talking about talking
[ __ ] to him after the fight and he was
like and then after the press conference
he was like first of all not my best
side
very sorry to do a UFC however what is
deal with Conor though it's like a
worship worse apology of all time
okay listen I'm gonna say not my best
side for what is deal with bus situation
though Conor through shared bus and why
nobody talking about it you know
okay look sit down sorry now current
what about him worst apology imagine
going out with that guy you cheated on
me rushing him Jenna get off yes but
what about how you tits out a little bit
you have cleavage what
you [ __ ] different girls
what about how when I have my hat on you
don't say nice head you don't say you
say I i have furry hat on what about
when you don't say nice hat
what about that sorry about the gangbang
but also why you not talking about my
head you know so so so that was the
worst apology of all time but it is also
a esse Russian you know he talked about
my dad have to finish personal business
have to do business then have to finish
personal business I love how Conor
McGregor loses now cuz he's just so like
he's so hey I lost but I got a hundred
million dollars you know it's awesome
he's like yeah I lost but let me just
[ __ ] by another Lamborghini later buy
a Bentley my Irish friend loves Conor
McGregor it's so funny he'll go to war
with other people who are just [ __ ]
continent writing about Conor McGregor
badly on Twitter he'll just find him and
start writing him like it's a Irish but
yeah I don't know man that whole [ __ ]
cult it was also really bad I was like
the first time I watched his UFC [ __ ] in
a long time and like that happens it's
so [ __ ] bad for
this is the thing man UFC is mainstream
now it went from being a subculture to a
mainstream thing and it's huge and I'm
not talking about how much money ma'am
it makes so much money but but boxing
has been around since however long right
but but there are still people who don't
consider the UFC a sport now I think
those people are wrong I think they just
think of it as like barbaric and [ __ ]
like that and I think those people are
wrong but that's the kind of [ __ ] that's
gonna keep the UFC in though in that in
that subculture II area in some people's
minds you know and the fact that he that
was so bad I mean when I was when I was
watching the fight I mean I could hear
it in Rogen's voice too it was just like
it's just so shitty cuz he loves this
sport Joe you know and he loves that
it's a sport and he loves the
competition aspect of it but it's like
and then people are like oh yeah but you
you you paid to go watch a fight then
you got upset that a fight broke out
afterwards it's like those people are
[ __ ] idiots dude what are you talking
about you fight in the Octagon and
afterwards it's illegal and then I love
how Dana I love how Dana White too was
like oh these guys are net you know who
ever fought afterwards in the whoever
did that don't never fight in the UFC
and you know that's what [ __ ] what's
his name did come rushing the dinner
Jeff and you know that they're gonna let
him fight in the UFC again it's all
about money dude it's crazy I went down
a rabbit hole watching these conspiracy
video is about khabib number two Jenna
Dolph and oh by the way his full name
khabib abdomin Povich
nur Magnum Magomedov
never my god Norma Chamitoff Wow
that guy was [ __ ] legit when he was
holding on to when he was takin his legs
and holding Conor McGregor's legs
together like a [ __ ] Bell constrictor
crazy these fighters they have a
different [ __ ] mindset huh I didn't
get punched
I mean that hat that he wears you know
is it like a Russian thing why does he
look like a poeple um yeah I don't know
I've never really been sickened about
like I did this I shot that thing
Hollywood game night last night it'll
air [ __ ] far a long time ago of a far
from now but I did it with like Joel
McHale and Nikki Glaser and some other
people from this is us and and all that
[ __ ]
and and Jane Lynch hosts it you know
what's on NBC I'm I don't know but other
words on season 6 I love how these shows
can be on the air I've no [ __ ] idea
for how long
but um yeah they were like are you
competitive and I'm like they kept
asking like they did we did some [ __ ]
like interviews before hands that
they're gonna put on the online and [ __ ]
hey are you competitive and I'm like the
least competitive person I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm competitive with it myself
that's it like if I ran three miles
yesterday I want to run for the next day
my god that's it but if somebody's
running faster than me I don't give a
[ __ ] let him go go man go
what are we doing this for I'm not very
competitive but so these I when I did do
jujitsu for the limited amount of time I
did and when I wasn't very good ever but
I liked it because it was just me it was
just me it wasn't like anytime there's a
team involved like baseball basketball
football and we lose I'm always just
like everyone [ __ ] up I don't give it
like one time I was in high school when
I was in high school I was in the saw I
was on the sophomore team the basketball
team and I remember my buddy Tim Chung
we lost and my buddy Tim Chung cried
afterwards and I was like hey man why
are you crying dude and he was like hey
man maybe if you gave a [ __ ] about
something your life would be better and
I was like oh you're dribbling balls in
a high school yeah to be that passionate
about basketball is crazy to me but I
mean I do love when people are
passionate about their [ __ ] I love it I
just don't like when people are so
[ __ ] alpha quote-unquote about their
[ __ ] mm-hm anyway I don't give a [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] competition of all and
I was thinking about like why have I
never been like that then maybe it's cuz
if I dig deep into myself like maybe
it's because I know
I'm never gonna be the best but that's
the other thing too like cuz I'm not
athletic I'm not the [ __ ] guy who's
gonna be jumping and running and [ __ ]
you know I love to work out I like to
try and [ __ ] beat my [ __ ] but I'm not
the kind of I mean you know there's
always a guy that's gonna be better than
you so to me to me it's like why try but
I'm not that way about comedy because I
think comedy I guess it cuz it's a
subjective thing right there's no oh
he's the best right like LeBron is the
best player but there's no comedian
that's the best cuz some people who
think is the best comedian there are
people out there like Mia but I don't
like that guy sty doesn't make me laugh
I like this guy the best right so I
don't know maybe that has something to
do with it I was just trying to think
about all the times I was ever
competitive in my life like when we ever
play that game [ __ ] I remember one
time I was playing butts up remember
that game butts up it's a it's an East
Coast it's definitely an East Coast
thing and nobody it originated in the
East Coast I know it did I read up on it
once it's called butts up if you look it
up it's called butts up and it's always
there's a lot of different versions of
the game and what mainly is the thing is
you the main thing that butts up we
remember of a butts up there's the main
thing that makes it butts up is you got
a look at this [ __ ] on Wikipedia butts
up aka a ball asses up yeah we call that
something that's sometimes a seize
rehabbing T yeah Sooey
Bolivar shag nasties revenge that's what
it's called
Bolivar shag nasties revenge balls deep
ball Z's and bear trap
blackjack okay anyway a North American
elementary school children's playground
game originating in the 1950s or earlier
it is in North America it is slightly
similar to the game screen ball butts up
or booties up began in the 1940s 1950s
as a penalty phase of various City
Street games yeah basically you just put
your hands up against the wall and
people try to peg your butt with it and
we did it and I did it once and I never
really cared about it but one time there
was a guy he was a he was like a bully
kind of guy his name was Danny Brown and
Mike in my
in my school and he and I was like I
don't give a [ __ ] we got into some sort
of argument I was like how do I give a
[ __ ] I think it was like he was like oh
yeah you didn't do it right I was like
whatever he was like you didn't put your
hands on the thing as I find do it again
and he kept throwing the tennis ball at
my butt and I was like do it again and
he kept throwing the tennis ball at my
butt and they're like come on do it
again he was like yeah yeah and it
[ __ ] stung on my butt and a lot of
time you would miss but that was like I
was like I'm a real man dude I'm taking
these butts I'm taking these [ __ ]
tennis balls to my butts and he ain't
[ __ ] and he ain't [ __ ] and I'm doing it
and he's a bully
and he ain't [ __ ] cuz he was one of
those guys that was like a little bit
like girls didn't like him and he found
his like coolness in like being a bully
and I remember if that was like when I
first got to LA and I remember being I
remember then like using humor
cuz I would always like I would be like
dude I can make these [ __ ]
laugh and they'll be on my side there
was another bully named Tori and he
would like [ __ ] bully people and I
would just be like don't make this guy
laugh he's such a [ __ ] and I'd make him
laugh and then he'd be like dude he was
like on my [ __ ] nuts dude these
[ __ ] guys are [ __ ] man bullies are
[ __ ] dude oh my god does make him
laugh and then they're like oh I'll do
they want to know what you think about
everything yeah dude you [ __ ] [ __ ]
ask [ __ ] you know I it's like
it's like the kind of guy who can't like
bullies are so [ __ ] dumb because like
you can't express yourself with words
you get so frustrated that you need to
[ __ ] fight somebody like that's so
[ __ ] that's so [ __ ] [ __ ] when you
can't when you're so mad at somebody
you're like that's it only thing I'm
gonna do is punch you in the face don't
have enough words okay you made me mad I
don't have enough words here comes the
fist I remember you I remember being
like I can make these [ __ ]
laugh that's all I've ever thought of my
whole life is making people laugh that's
all I wanted to do I would want to get
buddy-buddy with my teacher I'd want to
get [ __ ] with the girls just making
them laugh and then [ __ ] the bullies
do it make them I don't know maybe just
I'm not that smart though I'm not that
I'm not that smart so maybe that's why I
did it I just did it to make people
laugh I don't know but I did but anyway
that blood sup [ __ ] was and [ __ ]
stupid games [ __ ] stupid games kids
trying to figure it out and [ __ ] alright
here we go
okay me undies you've heard me obsess
about my me on DS I love them they're
all the amazing colors and prints that
they offer but guys did you know that me
on DS also makes the world's most
comfortable lounge pants and T's yeah
not just underwear with fall finally
here which is good cos gets cold out now
is the perfect time to put these cozy
essentials to the test the lounge pants
are made from the same micro modal
fabric as their undies and they're
amazing I have on my lounge in them all
the time you'll be in fall heaven you
guys when you cover your entire bottom
half of the fabric that is three times
softer than cotton so if you do have me
undies imagine them longer all the way
down to your ankles what the undies also
love celebrating the fall season with
fun Halloween prints so since its fall
you can go check out their latest
jack-o'-lanterns print in undies socks
and bracelet and oh and bra let's I like
a bra let's they got Jack Jack O'Lantern
bra let's that's kind of dope
the best part when you join the
membership you can get all this stuff
lounge pants T's and undies everything
me undies makes for less than anyone
else a special member pricing is just
one of the many perks of joining the
membership the undies has a great offer
for one of my listeners for for munities
has a great offer for my listeners for
any first-time purchasers when you
purchase enemy undies you get 50% off
15% off and free shipping this is a no
brainer you get 15% off a pair of the
most comfortable undies you will ever
put on to get your 15% off your first
pair free shipping and a 100% Gatiss
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
dot-com / Congrats that's my undies comm
/ Congrats
hey guys loot crate you heard of this
what is a loot crate well a monthly
subscription box delivered direct to
your door with exclusive pop-culture
collectibles apparel and gear loot crate
curates designs everything themselves
you can't find these items anywhere else
no matter what you geek out about this
is for you over 30 million crates have
been sold our original and most popular
loot crate is a curated collection of
items from the best pop culture
franchises the October theme is all
about cursed just in time for Halloween
you have to check this out
so loot crate offers 16 other awesome
crates from gaming to anime including
their next most popular crate so it's
very cool loot crate packs $45
evaluating - each crate for less than
$20 a month you can't lose it's great
for giving gifts or do it yourself if
you want to if you want to gift yourself
something this crate will sell out you
must order by this week to guarantee
yours as this will sell out ok
Halloween's coming up do this now get
the best surprises each month from the
largest geek and gaming subscription
company geek out in style with loot
crate subscribe now by going to loot
crate calm / Congrats and enter my code
congrats to save an exclusive 30% off
your subscription subscribe now by going
to loot crate dot-com / Congrats and
enter my code congrats to save an
exclusive 30% off your subscription
Square cash you guys know this cuz your
babies you're my babies you already know
the cash app is the number one finance
app on the app store what you might not
know is that you can also put cash up in
your wallet with the cash card it's the
only debit card that offers instant
rewards and comes packed with premium
features not even a credit card can
offer like boosts save up to 10%
instantly at Whole Foods Wendy's or
Chipotle and more of your favorite spots
or even $1 off coffee every time you
select Swiper
card at coffee shops across the country
the cash card puts you in control of
your money with extra in-app safety
features that let you pause your card
with a touch unlike a credit card there
are no fees ever and a credit check
isn't required to get one download cash
app now and get your cash card free get
it for free visit the App Store or
Google Play market now and of course
when you download the cash app and enter
the referral code Congrats
you'll receive five dollars and the cash
app will send $5 - times up Legal
Defense Fund a true win-win let me tell
you something man are you at the age
where you're starting to uh this is not
an ad but it sounds like it is are you
at the age that's how it begins but are
you at the age where your nose hairs are
growing too long and how much does it
[ __ ] hurt when you pull out nose
hairs hey let me tell you something
that's how I know something extra is
going on it's not just life as we know
it
pulling your nose hair out of your
[ __ ] nose hurts like a gunshot wound
to your face it hurts so bad and it's
one of these pains - you know I'm
talking about it hurts so much
and and my nose hairs are so long right
now you can't see him I'm not like a
[ __ ] gross a [ __ ] but if I
hum mm-hmm my nose itches because the
hairs are touching each other and then I
get [ __ ] dude it hurts so bad when
you but I guess girls probably don't
have to think about this too much cuz
they don't grow a lot of the [ __ ] how
about when people put the wax up there
though and the q-tips and then they rip
it out like the hairdresser's you know
dude if you're going to get your hair
cut and they're working on your beard
and nose hairs and eyebrows to chop your
[ __ ] head off just go to a
Decapitator you know you see those
Instagram pages it's like barber fun or
like [ __ ] hair look guy and you go
and it's like a guy shaping his beard up
do it I
I went to the [ __ ] barber once
because actually when I did you just see
there was a guy who cut hair - he used
to [ __ ] by the way beat off in the
shower when it was scalding hot so he
could [ __ ] try and make himself think
pain was pleasure it's crazy but uh like
hair and beards on Instagram like this
[ __ ] you know they'll put it to music
and then they'll cut the [ __ ] hair
and then like they'll shape his beard
and eyebrows and then nose hairs like
lop your head off dude lop your head off
god I saw three guys coming back from
the airport
they were like all a version of each
other they were so [ __ ] funny and
awful looking they had [ __ ] horrible
hair all teed up too and then there had
like a long guy had a beard and faded
into his [ __ ] what do you call these
side sideburns it faded in is like the
beard was full and then it faded out and
then back into his sideburns the guy
looked like a [ __ ] utter piece of
[ __ ] and he was 5/6 course because he
was overcompensating oh hey man you're
too short so you got a funky beard see
right through you be reg I don't give a
[ __ ] how tall you are be reg it's free
conch fade your beard however you want
it but if you do just know you
overcompensating and they do they were
these guys you know the guys that are so
that think they're so cool that their
eyebrows change they're just like this
they're just like tired everything
they're just like this and I got like
jean jackets on and jeans with like some
[ __ ] Jordan Elevens on and their
beard is all shaped and they use
hairspray oh dude
is it 1997 and is your name George Kim
in my luck and yet high school dude are
you using hairspray guy what are you
doing hey lop your head off just [ __ ]
use pomade or
nothing just get a [ __ ] waxy [ __ ]
if you're a dude and you're going like
this to your [ __ ] head ah I'm sorry
but the [ __ ] here come the police ah
I want to make hairspray that every time
it sprays it just goes no no no no no no
no no no every time you spray it or
every time you spray it it goes like
this dude I don't know man it's so funny
when dudes think they're good-looking I
just can't stand it dude when guys like
are doing this face and then they got
tattoos and they're all barbered up
leaning against a [ __ ] old truck and
they're cuffed jeans you know [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] half these guys look like
Ace Ventura if they [ __ ] if they
rubbed Chea mix all over them do you'd
look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] with his
hair who are you he's like the [ __ ]
Armenian Johnny Bravo
this guy you gotta [ __ ] put that on
that thing on the video pot or meanie
Johnny Bravo bravo any in johnny-bra
Vinny and hey guys I'm Johnny bro Vinny
in I owned a [ __ ] cell phone shop hey
guys do you need a family plan I'm
Johnny Bravo Vinny in enough with sprint
you need to come on over to t-mobile
hey man I'm Johnny Bravo Vinny in I've
got [ __ ] I live in LA kenyatta up
near [ __ ] Angeles Crest Highway dude
so many [ __ ] Armenians lived in
locking at it I [ __ ] I love al of
Armenians dude I love all you know I
[ __ ] love all and also I hate all you
gotta like and hate everybody the same
otherwise you ain't [ __ ] you know
if you don't love and hate everybody the
same then your Republican dude I posted
a a [ __ ] picture of millennia Trump
and how she looked like how about Donald
Trump wrote Melanie Trump once on his
[ __ ] Twitter hey guy you're the
president's also spell your wife's name
right
I put lmao come on get with it millennia
and I put spy vs. spy thing next to her
[ __ ] don't dress like that
hey millennia the [ __ ] are you doing you
smooth criminal dude win millennia
dressed like that and then she dude and
she's in front of a [ __ ] Sphinx
no wonder if he was that more carmen
sandiego but so i posted the thing we're
side-by-side it looked like her and then
the [ __ ] white spy versus spy called
the dynamite dude and then she was like
i wish they did an interview about it
they were like i wish people would
concentrate on what i do not what I wear
oh really
then don't dress like Michael Jackson in
smooth criminal' and also do more and
it's not a political thing I don't give
a [ __ ] dude
I posted that because it was funny okay
and people are like oh really you're
gonna be political now huh
no nothing is political about making
people say stay out of politics what are
you talking about not in politics I'm
first of all making fun of what she's
wearing she's the president's wife it's
not even the president and then people
are like yeah stay out of politics it'll
be like if I posted a picture of [ __ ]
LeBron James made fun of his outfit and
people were like hey man
stay out of basketball I'm not [ __ ]
also because I make fun of her it
doesn't mean I'm in politics
what am i a politician you're only in
politics if you're a politician what the
[ __ ] are you talking about I'm making
fun of all of this [ __ ] you can't pick
and choose what you make fun of then
you're a [ __ ] then you're then you're
you know what I mean
[ __ ] that I have no boss I have no boss
I'm my own boss I'm out here doing this
[ __ ] you make fun of what millennia
Trump the president's wife wears
and Republicans went nuts although I
made fun of some other [ __ ] and people
liberals got mad - [ __ ] that dude I
don't want to be a liberal I don't want
to be a conservative that's how
everybody [ __ ] it all up
now I'm not any of them I'm me that's it
dude I don't want to be I don't want to
be you know I don't want to be
considered any of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] em all they're all wrong dude
when someone was like oh I was I was
talking about what's that I tweeted
something because people were like some
guy I got a job on Charlie's Angels some
actor got a job on Charlie's Angels from
this Netflix movie and some girl some
everyone was like nobody could just be
happy for the guy they were like yeah
but let's not forget the girl - lets get
Lissa hopefully she gets parts - like
you just be happy for the [ __ ] guy
you know and people on the Internet and
then it became a Twitter moment and it
was like people are our hope that this
girl gets parts - and it's like dude I
get the movement but Cass where the [ __ ]
you want to cast so I just wrote yeah or
just cast whoever you want to cast and
don't listen to the internet dude
liberals went nuts man they were just
like people are rooting for Lana Condor
to get the same amount of roles as Noah
sent something sent what is it Noah sent
teenie Oh Centennial and people to lie
and people were like oh yes so Chris you
should just get [ __ ] more white guys
get roles to like not shut the [ __ ] up
first of all it's not what I'm saying
obviously
stop pushing everything to fit your
[ __ ] agenda it's art dude
cats whoever the [ __ ] you want it's art
you want to cast the [ __ ] a [ __ ]
Mexican guy cast a Mexican guy you want
to cast an Asian girl cast an Asian girl
if there's not enough opportunities out
there then create the [ __ ]
opportunities I don't give a [ __ ] but
stop complaining dude the
[ __ ] who complain they're not
doing [ __ ] you're not doing anything to
help you're not doing anything rub
peanut butter all over your [ __ ] face
that that's just that's what you're
doing it's unnecessary
oh you're tweeting something you tweet
an outrage rub peanut butter all over
your face it works the same put peanut
butter in your [ __ ] ears works the
same yeah I don't know it doesn't matter
what you say anymore if the more and
more of the time passes doesn't matter
what you say anymore cuz people just
move on to the next one the next day
mmm you know what I ever eat I'm some
outrage [ __ ] happens I always saying oh
let's see what happens tomorrow nobody's
gonna give a [ __ ] and then the last time
that happened the next day they didn't
give a [ __ ] and I was like I gotta
remember to talk about this on podcast
this is how much nobody gives a [ __ ]
anymore I forgot what the [ __ ] it is I
don't even remember what it is I was
gonna talk about it on the podcast at
the Kavanaugh thing I mean everyone knew
that he was gonna get a lab well how did
we pretend that that was gonna affect
anything nobody's voting nobody's [ __ ]
gonna vote people are like yeah but you
got a vote it doesn't matter you're not
gonna [ __ ] vote vote then vote then
you're not gonna you're not gonna
nothing's gonna change if you don't
[ __ ] vote it's as simple as that
you're not gonna vote because you don't
want you know why you don't wanna that's
why yeah but you got other [ __ ] to do
you'd rather go [ __ ] whatever it is
you'd rather go walk your dog or drink a
coffee with your friends or [ __ ] text
some chick or some guy you'd rather text
you don't want to vote your other texts
you don't want to everyone's like yeah
but our time is coming everything's
getting overturned soon we're gonna
[ __ ] we're gonna we're gonna change
the change is coming the pendulum swung
the other way no it didn't no it didn't
dude we're [ __ ] I guess you still got
a try I guess but just stop complaining
dude that's the thing
I saw the thing Tammy Lauren is that her
name Tommy Lauren she was like whatever
liberals you can keep whining but we're
gonna keep winning like what what are
you [ __ ] winning who winning you know
this is the country we talk about
winning the whole Republican versus
Democrat thing is so [ __ ] stupid
dude I started reading the beginning of
that book of fear that book fear with
Donald Trump he was like a he was like
trying to run for he was like I want to
be the president and then Steve Bannon
was meeting with him and he's like well
a lot of stuff you've done if you want
to run for president and as a Republican
a lot of stuff you've done like 80% of
your donations have been to Democrats
and she was like oh we could fix that he
just want to be present you think of a
[ __ ] but yet to fit into that box of
Republican for it to work out it's a
game dude and when and then and then so
it's like you want to be Republican you
want to be Democrat and then you got a
well true Democrats don't really you
know they're not pro-life the pro-choice
so but if you want to run as a Democrat
and then if you if you go as pro-life as
a Democrat you're not gonna get the
[ __ ] votes to be the the Democratic
nominee when if that's what you believe
in if that is what's right and if you do
believe that so it's right that's never
gonna come [ __ ] see the light of day
you're not gonna be a Democrat and be
pro-life so then you a Republican then
you got to change all the other [ __ ] and
you got to be a Republican you got to be
a [ __ ] against gay marriage and [ __ ]
which is so rude all of it is so [ __ ]
ridiculous all of it is so ridiculous
there shouldn't be the [ __ ] the the
two-party system like that earn them
more into parties but there shouldn't be
that that shouldn't be how it's done now
now I'm a [ __ ] idiot
I have no oh it should be this way
though well I'm just saying dude that's
so insane how it works I don't I don't
know I don't know
but that's it I don't know was that what
did I start talking about that way oh
when I was talking about how people
should have liberals really true true
liberals really are crybaby though it's
like you you gotta get it together dude
you got to stop [ __ ] crying and
whining about [ __ ] you have to otherwise
and and and you know otherwise look you
don't want Trump to win again liberals
you have to stop whining and bitching
and moaning otherwise Trump's going to
get elected again and it's going to be
your fault that's it that's it stop
whining and bitching and moaning
otherwise what you don't want to happen
will happen that's it and Republicans
know it and all I gotta say is yeah it's
crazy it's crazy how they double down on
that [ __ ] to God they double down that's
some gangster [ __ ] Trump they wanted
Republicans wanted nothing to do with
Trump when he started [ __ ] up and
then when he did though grab her by the
[ __ ] thing hey you know bragging about
sexual assault dude the Republicans
wanted nothing to do with him and then
he [ __ ] doubled down and he was like
its locker room talk [ __ ] it didn't it's
all good he doubled the [ __ ] down and
people were like okay that's how much
people want a leader they don't even
know they don't even care what they
[ __ ] believe they just want somebody
to believe it more okay I guess he's
right if he's saying it like that you
know it's like they they don't they're
not the bad guy if the other guy is
saying the [ __ ] well if something goes
wrong it wasn't me that said it I'm just
following that's the guy that said it so
I'll just [ __ ] go you know
I'm sure [ __ ] hitting a button if you
if you click a button and that kills
someone that's way easier than stabbing
him in the [ __ ] neck it's a
difference you know you click a button
someone dies you're removed from it dude
it wasn't me it was the button it was
the [ __ ] I was removed from it you
stabbed someone in the neck you got to
look him in the eyes got real dark head
anyway what's the we have two questions
together we got questions Twitter
questions I'd like to help these
[ __ ] let's get this podcast out
there a little bit more ok share and
also tell your friends about this
podcast right now put it on pause and
just tell em and text somebody you gotta
listen to this podcast and go to your
favorite episode incident and and send
it to them
alright Twitter questions thoughts on
micro this is by Steve from Steve Steve
Bush tweets I thought what oh this guy's
an elder okay cool thoughts on my
co-workers referring to look Kroy as
work beers Wow
I mean how much of an alcoholic can you
[ __ ] possibly be to call the croix
work beers
I don't like cute [ __ ] like that man I
don't understand what about the Lacroix
thing you see about how they're [ __ ]
they might have what is it pesticides
what is it it's got to be [ __ ] right
it's got to be [ __ ] you can't have
[ __ ] poison in your sodas well I mean
Coke and Pepsi does but you can't have I
don't know although but then it's like
yeah but it's a chemical taste
there's no [ __ ] sugar or whatever in
it but then it tastes like a [ __ ]
berry so I mean it's something's going
on in there oh it's not water
oh it's water but it doesn't taste like
water oh it tastes [ __ ] it tastes
better than water though so I got a
question
you know what is that do you know no one
fire Ivan get rid of they don't know I
don't know that's three guys so what the
[ __ ] is it tasting like berries for if
nothing's in it got quick question
but yeah that's crazy dude did does look
for a cause cancer hope not if it does
got it between that and the ice-cream
sandwiches
got it we're all gonna get cancer though
it's it that's it that's why when I go
to foreign countries which is never I
[ __ ] eat as much as I possibly can
because their food isn't it has his
stricter have you had any form of vocal
training Jordan at Jordans vegan have
you had any formal vocal training well
with that I got a [ __ ] I got a tell
it to you like this you do the math dude
have you ever ticket singing lessons you
do the math mmm this answer your
question have you had any formal vocal
training dude I used to [ __ ] do I
like this question cuz they lit they
leave me sometimes on to some topics we
had a [ __ ] I did chorus when I was
like in eighth grade and this actually
was probably the term the time I coined
to submit okay mr. Kelsey remember him
okay so mr. Kelsey would go we would do
vocal and here we go you know the vocal
exercises would be like okay let's start
off class mail Mayo Mayo Mayo may Mayo
Mayo Mayo Mayo may I get so high into
you're just like man okay [ __ ] it
and there was one where we would do
where we would go and he would do Oh on
the video pockets but you see it he
would go from low to high and every time
we do it he would let he would like jump
a little bit and every time it happened
I was laugh so hard now be like wow it
was so [ __ ] whenever he would do it he
would go and he would jump a little bit
first of all doing this so [ __ ]
this with his [ __ ] with his fingers oh
dude he died guess what died of cancer
everyone's getting it babies but dude he
would he was so [ __ ] with his [ __ ]
so [ __ ] with his [ __ ] do you ever get
that really sharp neck pain that happens
and you're like what the [ __ ] for no
reason do you guys ever get that yes it
like pops what is that dude the first
time I ever got that was in chorus and I
thought somebody behind me shot me with
a bow and arrow and I was and I went
what the [ __ ] and I looked at the girl
behind me her name was Tenny I always
had a secret crush on her why is her
name Kenny but um
God what are these [ __ ] people doing
now how about everybody that was in my
class now is like 40 and they just have
kids and they're divorced a lot of them
are fat you know and I and and and dude
[ __ ] I look behind and I said did you
just [ __ ] do something to Tenniel's
like did you just stab my neck and she
goes she goes she goes like this
what and then mr. Kelso is up there
going oh so [ __ ] dude anyway so I have
had some vocal training anyway but there
was so after that though I remember I
saw Moulin Rouge and I was like if I'm
an actor I'm gonna [ __ ] be I got to
know how to do that [ __ ] if these
[ __ ] musicals are about to pop off
and if you and McGregor can do this [ __ ]
I got to be able to do this [ __ ] so I
started taking vocal lessons and I did
it for about three years and I took it I
took it from a guy with a wonky eye a
camera but it was but he was always
looking at me and behind me and yeah I
would go every week and I would [ __ ]
dude singing is hard dude I people who
can sing are [ __ ] amazing man and
they can make they can make you
emotional emotional city it no [ __ ]
what's it from Sopranos yeah you think
it's genetical they can make you
emotional just by [ __ ] just by just
by singing dude that's crazy
they can make you emotional just by
going
like that [ __ ] who's that who's that
[ __ ] Maxwell guy is that him that's
his name you hear two notes of that and
you're just like ah you know you [ __ ]
did vocal exercises like mr. Kelsey whoa
[ __ ] dude
so I took like three four years five
years of vocal and [ __ ] I was like I
can't do this [ __ ]
I could sing a tune I could knock it hum
you know I could [ __ ] I could get it
going a little bit but do it [ __ ] these
[ __ ] who kill do it there's
these videos that go viral about people
singing and [ __ ] just like on radio
stations and I cry watching those
[ __ ] man I cry watching those
[ __ ] and they're good I can't
do this [ __ ] I tried I can't do it not
singer baby I'm a comedian
so that's your answer to Jordan's vegan
change it Nate flake at Nate underscore
flake got it's sucks when you have to
[ __ ] and use that underscore doesn't it
you were too late to the game
hey [ __ ] johnny-come-lately what's up
Nate flake who gave you the biggest push
to start the podcast uh it was just kind
of me
I didn't know nobody ever really was
like you got to do a podcast I just knew
that other comedians had successful ones
like Bill bursts Tom Segura and Rogan
and I was like I'm leaving money on the
table so I decided to [ __ ] do it and
I didn't know that it was gonna help me
[ __ ] back up the Brinks truck I
didn't know it was gonna make my pockets
wall I didn't know it was gonna make me
look like I had extra [ __ ] around my
waist I didn't know this podcast was
gonna make it look like I had [ __ ]
sandbags in cargo pants dude I didn't
know that oh these [ __ ] isn't
are they [ __ ] with my money
oh these [ __ ] is [ __ ] with
my money right for those people who
think I'm not making money on the
pockets yeah dude I took a hot we were
taking a hike huh some about we were on
a hike me and my Irish buddy we're
coming down the [ __ ] hike and these
two chicks were near us talking so loud
when chicks talk loud it's sad that said
dude I I wanted to get in a car start it
drive it into a wall lightly to where
it's like [ __ ] I'm I didn't get hurt but
if was thinking harder I could've got
hurt and then I want to [ __ ] leave
the car there and walk away dude they
were just talking and then she said this
and then that and it and that's why
we're talking about Latino my god
talking about an Ilana and did it why
not and me and Mark we were just like
imagine [ __ ] we were on this hike
with this [ __ ] with these chicks they
were loud dude and use your [ __ ] when
people talk and you're talking like this
you can hear me you hear me talking like
this yeah we're just talking to [ __ ]
some people are just and their chicks
dudes but nothing when a chick has that
[ __ ] it's just cuz it's high enough to
where it just [ __ ] you up dude it
[ __ ] up your whole it's like
interference you know I just can't
[ __ ] deal with loud chick talkers
it's just like oh man
also there's something to with like a
dude if a dude's talking that loud you
can be like a man will you shut the [ __ ]
up and then to do to laugh you know
but if you do that to a chick she'll be
like what are you what so it's like
control your [ __ ] voice you know
whoever you are that should drives me
nuts dude no my biggest pet peeve is of
all time though is when somebody says do
you like I'm trying to give an example
like when they when they don't when they
say something you don't hear them you
say what and then they just repeat the
second part of what they said
hey man I most likely didn't hear the
[ __ ] first part because I wasn't
paying attention and then when you
started talking I had to start paying
attention and you're just gonna tell me
the last part like like when they say
[ __ ] like um I went to the library the
other day get those books and you say
what is hey I got those books nope
[ __ ] nope that's not what you said
dude what about those or sometimes they
just repeat the NAT they're like yeah
man read those books the other one is so
good
say what so good what so good did you
did you check on the cake what the cake
what the cake what is what about the
cake did you check on it oh cool so we
could have avoided all this [ __ ] if you
just said what you said again step out
gunk that drives me nuts you do the math
I do we have another one or no that it
ok that's it then that's it dude if you
want me to keep doing this podcast you
got a [ __ ] chair it and [ __ ] I'm not
oh I don't give a [ __ ] man
I'll stop [ __ ] if we ain't
grown if your business ain't growing
you're dying if you don't grow you die
ok now our shits been [ __ ] going up
and up and up and up but you know if I
see a dip I'm I want to give up I want
to stop I want to stop I don't give a
[ __ ] I'll stop doing the podcast I'll
just do talk I'll just do comedy tours
if you like a podcast rate and review it
and [ __ ] share it with people man and
make your [ __ ] friends you want
you a baby make your friends listen to
it I don't get dude we're not if we
don't grow we die I'm telling you if we
don't row we die do it I'll take this
eagle right off the wall I'll take this
[ __ ] kuda
I'll make the I'll turn this room right
here in my house into a [ __ ] theater
I don't give a [ __ ] I'll turn it into
another kitchen for no reason I'm
disrespectful to [ __ ] dude I'll put I'll
turn this [ __ ] studio into a
kitchenette dude so help me out help us
out dude
otherwise there's no log cabin
but we do love you if you listen thank
you very much download the cash app for
free on the App Store or Google Play
market and two rewards code Congrats get
$5 and give $5 - times up you can
download my app on the in the App Store
just type in just type in Krista Lea and
Miami I'm coming Krista Lea calm West
Palm Beach Florida Jacksonville and I'm
excited for my show coming up a carnie
at Carnegie Hall here next week it's all
sold out but if you'll be there I'm
excited and we'll see you there
video podcasts go up Tuesdays Wednesdays
please share this show otherwise you
know the [ __ ] are we doing this for we
got to grow we've got it make it grow
we've got to make it grow okay guys
remember dude Johnny prevenient here to
say whatever the [ __ ] ah see you later
[Music]